wow wow wow wow
wow which bits The Toasted bit yeah I I
never have recommended the ravioli I
mean they're raw yeah a lot of people
don't like that they're either really
raw or they're just like cardboard she
doesn't know talking about I mean
they're dangerous does she eat them
Tatiana does she eat that dish no no
will you ask her to taste one for me
okay and then I think she'll 86 them all
right toasted ravioli R yeah sounds like
the owner a toast he said taste it and
agree with him in 86
it don't say anything to the chef just
let them be calm tell with then no it's
okay I can't take food back there none
of us can take food back there that's
not how it's supposed to go you're
supposed to go straight to the chef and
say this is wrong this is the food that
the matter fruit of the mar wow it's
bizarre looking fruit of the Mari okay
great thank you my d
past's
mush way over a c oh my
God strands of mozzarella is that
mozzarella on top of there yes it is an
futari and then the pasta It's just mush
it's almost like it's canned um the
muscles taste um like Old St are they
fresh muscles I don't think so and the
shrimps this ones are way over C and
these strange yeah this has been going
on for like a month or two now he's just
been sitting out bad trip and we don't
know why Genevie doesn't shut up and do
you not tell the chef well I can't take
complaints to the chef seriously um
Tatiana doesn't really listen to any of
us wow not
good what the hell is that still lasagna
I the
lasna the lasagna is vile it's
embarrassing seem to serve that to Chef
Ramsey what's in the sauce why is it
that color it's pink sauce she doesn't
know what's in it pink sauce with lasna
is it his own recipe yes it
is the sauce tastes aada and the um
mouthful I had was um stone cold it's
hot one side cold the other is that
microwaved it might be don't don't
answer a question you don't know
oh
wow right um is there a problem with
these microwave no but I'm aware it
feels like the microwaves on the blink
yes it is wow when a restaurant can't
get food microwav properly all time low
let me answer these
questions still there's always hope for
the pizza you look another like that all
right maybe we can win him over with the
pizza it's
crispy
pizza what it oh here's my pizza the
garlic chicken
oh God I hope he likes
something
[Music]
zo so Brey so doughy and got all this
raw pastry underneath there oh no he
doesn't like the pizza it resembles
nothing homemade oh my God they've got a
pizza that's come out of the oven that
feels like something that's being
frozen he hates our pizza he hates our
pizza what a
shame oh dear is it is it that bad Chef
uh yeah it's not funny uh I don't know
what the giggles and the Laughing is
about but the dishes have been Dreadful
okay I'm trying not to cry but he's
going to come after me I can feel it
menu the menu is huge right the menu is
huge the last I counted there was 126
things on there okay great right let's
start off with oh fried ravoli love them
okay do you know what about Linguini
esor okay what is the Catch of the Day
that's mahi mahi let's do that
absolutely perfect thank you so much
thank
you deco's hideous is stuck in a Time
Walk takes me back to
1981 okay I have a fried ravioli for
Chef Ramsey fried ravioli for the chef
my food is the best food that's possibly
made but the problem with the restaurant
place we fighting so much FR R
oil
okay Fri ravioli what's inside the
ravioli please uh it's a five cheese
stuffed ravioli and the five cheeses are
uh I'm not sure wow it's a pre-made
ravioli so they're not homemade those
are not homemade if we don't even make
them here it' be nice to know what's
inside them I'll find out right now for
you thank you how's it going I need to
find out what cheeses are in the ravioli
what cheeses are in the ravioli yeah
what kind of cheese is in the bread
ravioli read the
box it's a rotta cheese Jo to recard
cheese oh my
go ah horrible there something deep
fried frozen doesn't even taste like
cheese Jesus no you got a whole uh whe
and you got American Grana and a skim
cheese yeah okay perfect you got it
thank you yes yeah not good je
rsey I checked on the cheeses for you uh
mascapone mascapone rotta rotta uh also
American Gana something called a cheese
we and culture blend where the [__] is
that from in Italy I don't I have no
idea where that's from o and a uh
skimmed cheese skimmed cheese in a fried
ravioli what does that mean it's
fat-free cheese dipped in fat dipped in
fat
yeah extremely hot
crunch oh no God I hope the tamali are
moist
Jesus it's like soaking wet
newspaper jeez that is so
dry good
to my goodness me that's a fresh tato
well we make them we make them in big
batches and then they're steamed and and
then they're served because we make such
large volumes at a time so you're
sounding like the cun company now yes
and they go out like that it's they
should be wet enough with the sauce
inside that when you ream them they stay
moist what an embarrassment and this is
your Chef that ran a C Business
correct Jesus okay
okay hates the smalles really
H hates them he said it's so dry it's
inedible he said it's
embarrassing yeah very dry are you
cooking everything yeah PE are you
cooking the chimies
uh-huh I use the micro wait for Chim
Changas for 1 minute before they fry
they taste really really really good
okay chicken Chim
Changas
oo chimy chimy chimmy chimmy
[Music]
changa it's dry it's shards of dry
chicken God now
what here's the thing honestly chimmy
Chango chimmy Chucky in the bin what a
shame Hera he hates the chimies he
didn't like them I taste before it's
really good and flavor not to him
apparently I'm frustrated at my kitchen
it's a bit of a punch to the gut about
my
food steak
[Music]
burrito look at
that that is gross that has to be the
biggest ad for any diaper anywhere in
California oh
no oh
God my God Jesus that's like eating wet
cardboard have a taste of that
[Music]
please about to the steak was gy was
kind of like a car wash moist and mushy
oh my God that is
disgusting let me taste the steak he
says the steak tastes like [__] did you
grill him fresh steak for his burrito
yeah you didn't pull it from here
right didn't we taste everything before
we put it
[Music]
out it's really salty nobody tasted
before we did this there's the sign but
Grill 303 what the [__] is that maybe
I'm too
late Grill yes the
sunrise oh dear oh dear how are you very
well inde thank you grill 303 or Festa
Fiesta sunr okay good Fiesta sunr nice
to see you nice to meet you I thought it
was too late I thought it was the new
restaurant already oh well we don't
change the the little logo in the front
you haven't changed the logo on the
front no and it's been like that for how
long for a year and a half a year and a
half yeah okay right Jesus what's that
this is a new uh favorite of that we
have in it
here so it's complimentary complimentary
exactly wow yeah so you don't have to
buy for drinks you just come up here and
well you know when the people they
coming in we try to be you know give us
something to appetize her to start tost
strong there are
take right that's put some warm on my
balls okay yes should sit down please
excellent so that's
free right wow look at the size of this
place so how many seats have you got
there 120 120 120 yes wow how many book
for lunch two
tables okay what would you recommend the
combination number one number one
combination one tackle you have one
tackle one burrito and one is shil okay
yeah I'll try one of the fitas as well
okay I'm hoping that Chef Ramsey kick we
is
back what is that on there looks like I
got a sticker on my menu just trying to
peel it off and it's bugging
me h
H they art a
Mexican
cookie what is that under there the name
of the what name is that it was uh my
another restaurant I used to
have fiesta garabal Fiesta gaboli yes so
you brought the old menus from the old
restaurant into the new restaurant and
stuck some cell tape on there exact yes
and is that restaurant still open no
with close and you called it Fiesta
Sunrise as opposed to Fiesta Gabi cor
yes I'm really confused for same Chef
same Chef same ingredients same
ingredients you brought the ingredients
from the old restaurant into this
restaurant oh well you know different we
buy fresh same fresh ingredi yes
correcty
hell that have you got a bin yes Jeff
the mouse just by the front door huh I
it's by the door no we just had the
Exterminator you paid for the
Exterminator sure get your money back
okay that's not funny I've got an
incinerator outside can you take that no
as a general manager do something with
it the mouse the
mouse it was in the entrance as I walked
in on the left hand side bab Mouse a
mouse we always have the Exterminator
once a month to for prevention are you
ser
serious no [__] way up now come on at
the front door not even in the
kitchen hey guys be careful of
mice can you show me where you found
that at it was at the front door like
where oh where's the front door in your
mind I can't believe that I came in the
door walked in there saw him bang right
there right here do you have it on film
are you kidding me what you thought I
brought it in out of my pocket yeah I
think you did are you are you are you
[__] dreaming I arrived the mouse was
there never never never here never there
was no no never no mouse right here
right okay AB so we had the Exterminator
last week they come on regular occasions
we have an issue with mice that's why
you have an exterminator we we don't
have an issue with mice and Terminator
comes in regular just let's let's you
know I do a little investigation let's
[Music]
go Dwayne when was the last time you
spotted a mouse in here I've never seen
one never seen one
good except that one that was under the
steam table that was been a few months
back almost a year
back he found a mouse in the front door
I've never been so embarrassed and
humiliated in my life this is ridiculous
really ridiculous
and
sad I never seen a m
him perhaps you planted that um
Mouse and you a suggesting that I
brought it in I was like hm I put it
together like just for TV sake maybe I I
wish you would talk a little bit of
sense [__] the TV put your money where
your mouth is in front of your staff I
want to meeting upstairs with you and
everybody
now ping mice out of his pockets and
stuff you got to take some
responsibility for something man how you
going to help this if everybody keep
bullshitting man a mouth in the front
matter it's it's mice infested all over
this place it can happen it can
happen look at James For Me 2 seconds I
walked in the front door a mouse the
mouse that you planted I know they told
me but it's okay no it's not okay a show
it's got nothing to do with TV nothing
to do with your business in the [__] I
am not going to stand there and even
attempt to take that crap from you you
can take your restaurant and stick it
I'm gone I'm out of it you out of here
I'm out of here excuse me go see you
later that is salmon that's just
marinated in it's like an Italian
dressing
oh dear what's this oh seafood
restaurant on the water tuna and dyed
pink to make it look authentic look at
it my God unbelievable and here we
have that looks like the mushroom rotto
great Roto
unbelievable alarmed by the state of the
kitchen Gordon is anxious to take the
staff on a tour good morning there's
something I want to show you guys yeah
come with me
come
in the general hygiene of this fridge is
a [__] joke right come around walking
around want to get up to speed looking
at the ingredients checking what is
that is that just taken from the steam
table and dumped on the trolley and then
whis in here that's exactly what it is
that should be straight in the
trash hey I ate here yesterday no I'm
not happy whoever's responsible 40 years
in the business well experienced
you have to seriously start opening your
eyes this place is not right here we got
no chance I did not know that was going
on item after item oh I was pissed
what's this here I believe it's beef STS
beef bits in blood that's nasty I need
some answers AJ it's pretty terrible and
you know a lot of it lies on AJ there's
no excuse for it and that's the that's
the classic of the day that ladies and
gentlemen is a risoto take a good look
unfortunately it's not a drawing
that's real serious [__] at its best
it's a
joke look at the [__] color of the
chicken AJ come have a look at it yeah
you've got to see it AJ I do see
it my father doesn't want to deal with
the back of the house the back of the
house is falling apart that's my
frustration I'm sorry but it's not right
it's got to be somebody's
responsibility I'm not going to take
responsibility it's the owner's fault
why would I blame myself for that I'm
not going to blame him for that
unbelievable trusting my dad is
obviously not working look at where all
our money is gone I'm really mad right
now why is it bubbling cuz it's
old
that's we'll get rid of all no no no no
no no no Nick I know you're busy yeah
I'm [__] [__] myself now I feel
when you know things aren't going good I
I just assume get out you know just move
on to the next thing Hey where's Brian I
know you want to run away from it I'm
not running I can't run away from it
yeah I've just been watching and [__]
[__] myself for the last hour what
are you doing to people give me an
[Music]
answer you know we can't oversee
everything we assume that okay take me
down to the Pidge I want to see how you
[__] really
work I cannot believe that this is how
you guys are running around restaurant
in my head I was thinking we're going to
be screwed that's what in there that's
the walkin freezer freezer that's a
Walkin freezer look at the mess here
what's this here bacon yeah obviously
bacon smartass that's from lunch yeah
yeah 5 years ago you leave a spatula in
there like that I'm sorry nah [__] off I
cannot believe what you guys are doing
here there was so much going on my head
was spinning my head was going to EXP
blad I I thought to myself this is a
disaster what's that in there [__] that
didn't get put oh my God I don't know
what the [__] that's oh [__] off oh my
god oh
[Music]
no this is not good R chicken that
should never happen you know should oh
my God Chris is [__] chicken against
raw chicken it's it's [__] hey Panini
head are you listening to me yes you're
going to kill someone I've eaten here
partners partners in climed you should
be ashamed we are ashamed you've just
contaminated the town and Nick Nick stop
yeah
everybody right now this is not a
romantic eat out this is a valentine
[__] Massacre it's a
disgrace how can you do this
I'm closing the place down switch it
off this is
shock what was last time this was clean
inside my
goodness look at that the floor it's
Cate with Grime oh
Christ oh my
God
when was the last time
Missy
hell oh Christ
the what on Earth is
that the smell you know what you do
wrong just take more take more control
of these guys and I feel that you don't
if you want me to take the control don't
go check and guess me about anything
that I
do behind here oh my God [__] look at
that there that is mouse or rat
droppings oh my
God couple of hours ago I was feeling
slightly embarrassed for them slightly
concerned in a big way but now when a
chef let go over his kitchen like this
it proves he doesn't care I want to be
more involved in the business end of
things forget the business aspect and
your portion is the hosting
[Music]
portion I was going back to the hotel
couldn't sleep had a look in the kitchen
and I am absolutely [__] go smacked
how can you do that when that
is say that again what is that what is
that come
here Anthony how can you cook in this
when was the last time this was cleaned
the kitchen oh we try to do it on a
daily basis I mean what have you seen
under there underneath
underneath
here Joseph would you mind having a look
I don't think you've actually seen this
down there I see it look at that oh God
please Anthony talk to me give me some
form of
feedback don't [__] me give me
something please well they're asked to
do it every day the staff they're what
they're asked to do it every day we're
on our ass with half a million dollar
debt and you're telling me now that you
don't even clean that's what we we have
staff for right oh my
God what's this then what's that on
there the're droppings they're not
[__] carway
seeds was want to wear
them couldn't imagine it was been that
bad from the surface everything looks
nice and nice when you start digging I
can't just can't believe it isn't this
your Bedrock isn't this where it's all
created from you can't create jack [__]
from here
I swear to God I don't think you give a
[__] you should be absolutely
ashamed Chef M came in like a bad out of
hell and again just whipped the living
crap out of me there's only so much you
you could do or say so why
Anthony give me something please oh my
goodness I love you come up with an
answer Anthony Al I'm [__] out of
here I swear to God I am [__] out of
here
I can't take much more of this
[__] where you find that I found them in
the [__] fridge smell
them Vic look let me just show you
something what is
that I'm getting nervous now talk to me
what is
this that's the fish we using that's the
fish you're
using oh [__] me smell that in there is
this today's fish no um no they're fish
that was really scary because it was
smelling bad already I just couldn't
believe
it where's Patty yeah have a look at
this oh my god look how crispy and
curled up it is just touch that oh it's
it it's like
solidified what's this here just take
why is it all wrapped up in tin foil
look at the color of it it's oxidized
and what's that in there just pieces of
pork that's pork what have you done to
it why is it all stuck in there with
blood at the bottom of the tray why is
that how old is this stuff yesterday
yesterday he said Friday look at
that oh my
God when's all this from Friday he took
it out Friday oh everything's Friday
look let me just show you something look
how green a slime it is that's from
Friday
look look at that that's from Friday
look at my fingers
Friday look look there you go that's
from Friday how did you say this in
Spanish this is not healthy Sal thank
you what is going on in here a Hungry
Cat would walk away from that I was
mortified I felt embarrassed for letting
this go on for so long while customers
in the dining room continue to eat
subpar food Chef Ramsay's Kitchen
investigation
intensifies what is going on here what's
that the burritos what's that one the
chicken enchiladas oh
how oh my God what's that that was the
ground beef ground beef half of it's
[__] fat you idiot it's fatter than
you I felt satisfied that finally
somebody called him out on his [__]
oh [__] what's that the bean oh how it's
like a cement
mixer are you [__] stupid who's
controlling this I am CH you
are you are walking disaster now I'm
feeling like stupid lift it up the
fridge is full of
[__] it it's
disgusting I wasn't here on Saturday but
what would the expecting [__] 10,000
customers for lunch Patty I'm [__]
disgusted Yolanda that's a joke I
understand I don't want people to get
sick and I don't want them to spread the
word that put us bad here you're
overstaffed underw work [__] food I
wouldn't trust you running a bath let
alone a [__] restaurant you must be
out your tiny mind I don't care for I
want to take that out there I dare you
take it out there go on give it to them
yeah there you go it's with me look at
me why would you take it out there
that's embarrassing it's embarrassing
why are you serving it you don't [__]
care why why cuz you're serving that and
trying to charge people money for that
that's why you don't care I care this
you don't care [__] no [__]
way [__] ladies and
gentlemen I'm so sorry but we're
stopping
service